welcome to the recruitment relic coaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I'm really excited to be joined by
Gareth Morris who is the CEO of
evolution recruitment solutions who are
an international tech for creeping
business with offices in the UK Germany
Singapore Australia have circa
160 people in the business have been
going for 20 years
Gareth thank you for joining me it's
nice to be here
how have you been over the last couple
of weeks yeah good I mean really proud
of the response from from everyone that
works for the business everybody is been
mobilized and can work from home due to
a great effort from the IT team and you
know people are up for the fight that
they're working hard and they're doing
their best in in difficult circumstances
so we are gonna do our utmost to uncover
and unpack the last 20 years and
obviously you you've been in the
recruitment industry for a while
to say the least yeah so I'm excited to
sort of uncover the journey that you and
have been on but we're always like to
start on this podcast is how how did
Guerra fence of the the world of
recruitment let's start there okay I
graduated from Sheffield Hallam
University with a Business Studies
degree and great dreams to start a
business and I realized that although
I've got a theoretical knowledge of
business from the degree I actually
haven't got any practical experience but
by working in a bar so all through my
degree yeah used to chat sir it's my
best friend at University a guy called
Nick Elliot about starting a business a
dreaming of what we're gonna do and how
we're gonna start business when we
finished our degree so it's the summer
holidays after the degree I'm living
back at home and my mum says you need to
get a job and for any any any graduate
that's you know just left University
that's a bit of a shock isn't it to be
honest so I think from memory
could Nick cook on traveling and so I
looked in the back of the Manchester
Evening News and I saw this advert and
it said entrepreneurial people wanted
highly motivated great ot a fast-moving
industry IT recruitment has just thought
that advert sounds like me here was this
Gareth no you're asking 1997-98 that's
all the time
okay so I've rung them up and you know
pretty naive that didn't have a CV and
they said it will come for an interview
so I went for an interview met four
people and like the sound of recruitment
and what it was all about and and they
invited me back for a second interview
down in London and they said there's
just one thing we need to do to actually
write a CV so that was the first CV that
I wrote went down to computer futures
head office and and got offered the job
and and yeah that was the start of my
career in recruitment and and just just
for everyone's benefit how long did you
work there for before you started
evolution two years two years okay yeah
what's the computer futures part of the
s free brand right yes absolutely so
obviously we're gonna have a real focus
on evolution but just really quickly
always curious to sort of hear and ask
around people's experience in working in
for s free just because it's been the
the spawn of so many recruitment
entrepreneurism equipment businesses I
guess yeah
what how would you round up your
experience and how would you describe
the environment using and those two
years oh it was a really good great
great fun you know I just graduated from
University and I was working with a lot
of like-minded people I think that I
worked in the Wilmslow office and there
was a lot of people that were you know
degree educated bright and highly
motivated and and to be around that in
that environment was just just really
really good fun I think some of the you
know more negative stories you might
hear about s3 I didn't see
really any of that in my time there and
maybe that was something that was a
culture and perhaps other offices but
but certainly not up in up in Wilmslow
so yeah good fun work hard play hard
give you a great grounding in in
recruitment and you know you having the
time of your life you're young you free
single and you're working with other
people who are similar to you so what's
not to like living the dream in Wilmslow
absolutely okay so clearly always
obviously already had this sort of for
when is it you need to think about
starting your own business yeah so I
guess thinking back there and what what
do you think gave you the confidence to
start your own recruitment business
whether it has that come about I just
always wanted to start my own business
growing up so I can't really explain to
you why I used to be really into sport
and you know I'd go passport shops on
the way home and think I'd like to own
one of those one day and then at
university we had to do a placement year
and I applied for a number of jobs and I
got a job in marketing for a Vestas
steel in Sheffield
I just thought sounds really dull market
is a sells if you think recruitment
stuff that sounds really really bad so
what I did is I went to the University
and said do you know what there's only
so many placements I've got this
placement through through you guys but I
want to start my own business and
someone else can have my place at Vesta
steel in in Sheffield and they kind of
said well not before and I said well my
best friend at the time was it was a
locksmith and he wanted to start his own
business he had locksmithing skills I
had two years of a Business Studies
degree and you know truth be known
probably knew very little about anything
but we started that business in that
placement year so I saw him yeah I sold
my half of the business back to him for
the princely sum of five thousand pounds
when went back to university and from a
final year flush with with an extra five
grand in my pocket
however so where did this
entrepreneurial
sort of mine like what was your parents
like doing there an interest environment
growing up all good good question no I
love my mom and dad dearly and they were
brilliant parents very supportive never
really trying to tell me what to do they
only gave me one piece of advice and the
one piece of advice they said is you can
do anything you want in life just don't
be a teacher so they they were both
teachers and to probably felt that you
know although the holidays were good and
everything else it may be haven't hadn't
given them the lifestyle that they would
have hoped but you know obviously when
they were growing up a stable steady job
with a decent pension was what people
wanted so yeah they certainly weren't
entrepreneurial but what they did do is
encouraged me so if they want if I
wanted to do something they'd never say
oh no you can't do that yeah you wasn't
worried about failing or given things
ago which is possible right not I think
if you think back then like how was ins
preneur the cool thing to do probably no
it was the thing that you just said
again and steady job pension so I think
that's just really interested in that he
had that sort in a motivation yeah just
never appealed to me I said I think
reading you know Richard Branson's books
probably you know maybe as a teenager
think that sounds exciting you know
getting record labels and airlines and
things like that that maybe whetted my
appetite but I think it was just
something I always wanted to do and I
always thought I could do really yeah so
so so you obviously started in then
started the evolution recruitment in
2000 yeah yeah okay so just just paint
the picture very quickly like what what
was the landscape of the IT recruitment
market at that point well they've been
this new thing called the Internet
you know I remember someone in in in the
world's office starting a patch called
the Internet that's what they did that
was there that was that was their market
and I remember kind of going on a few
client visits and these
police saying yeah with 20 people now
but in two years time we're gonna have a
hundred people and there was the the.com
boom and there was a bubble where these
businesses were worth a huge amount of
money and being young and relatively
naive I didn't think you know the
dot-com boom was gonna become a combo so
I thought this is a great chance to
start business you know we evolution
which initially were specialized in
internet e-commerce and new media that
was our kind of strapline and about
probably 12 months in the dot-com boom
was rapidly followed by the dot-com bust
we we diversified out into you know our
IT recruitment rather than just
specializing in e-commerce internet and
and just quickly just for a run
listening context and obviously started
that business with common people yeah in
so Nick Elliot my business partner and
CFO and a friend of mine at the time who
was working recruitment the three of us
started the business and it was in the
cellar of my house we had to we've kind
of got the the cellar tanked and fitted
out and it was so damp down there that
we actually had to kind of lock the
paper away in a in a sieve Dana and we
did a year working literally underground
with no real lights pretty damp but it
was it was great time it was fun and I
think you know when we got the very
first check through the post for our our
first placement it was a kind of grey
source of celebration and I think that
that first year was about can we make
this successful enough to move out and
get our own office get a proper office
with windows and everything and and and
some lights so we managed to do that
after about 12 months but in 2001
obviously September the 11th happened
and anyone was working in the industry
at the time it it you know definitely
hit demand I'm not sure whether it is
officially a recession but there was an
awful you know there's a lot of
companies that stop recruiting and
the the third business partner at that
point was getting married and decided
that he wanted to steady job and an
income and move out and moved out of the
recruitment industry and then yeah Nick
Nick and I cracked on so going into the
sort of second year and if we'd just
sort of break it down I guess into sort
of early years of evolution so had that
experience in the year one where the
dot-com bust got out the cellar and
obviously ended up being new Nick I
guess sort of obviously obviously the
fact that I mean you're in the real top
percent of recruitment businesses in
terms of size so I guess in those early
days of evolution like what obviously
the mindset at that point was go out the
cellar but did you Nick have these sort
of big vision conversations of what what
this business could be or what what was
the sort of mindset early on on what the
intention was for the business was it a
business you wanted to grow or was it
just year by year focus on that yeah we
I think we've always tried to think
ahead and look ahead so probably when we
were you know a tiny business with two
or three people we tried to think like a
10 person business when we're tempers
and business trying to think like a 30
person business when were 30 person
business tried something like a 50
person business etc so yeah we were
always trying to plan ahead of what we'd
need to put in place to make the
business successful at the next stage
and I think we'd probably always
invested that the the money and the
profits of the business back in the
business to try and grow a great company
that was always always the goal really
to try and grow something significant
and sizable so I think you know on day
one did we start with the end in mind
we're going to be operating in four
countries now 160 people no we've not it
has been an incremental journey but I
think it's always trying to look to the
next stage and what you need to put in
place now to make that happen
mmm and I think that's I think that's
where a lot of people that's the
challenge that a lot of people have I'm
sure you now have plan to have had
plenty of conversations with other
recruitment business owners but yeah
from the conversations I have it's it's
the this is the opposite way around this
will do that when he gets 15 heads that
will do that when we hit this certain
milestone but very early on you as he
was doing was required before you got to
that point so that really enabled you
then yeah so that really enabled you to
to scale or obviously grown to grow the
business because that's how you're
thinking about it we just reinvested in
the business we weren't greedy ourselves
or you know some people that you meet
they have a little bit of success and
suddenly they've got a flash car and
everything else it's it's you know if
you're gonna grow something sustainable
in the long term you've got to reinvest
your time your effort and your money
back in back in that business and make
it stronger it's like if you're gonna
build a house you have to build it on
solid foundations you know you can't you
can't skimp on your foundations
otherwise the whole house will fall down
so that that's been the mentality that
we've we've always had really so what
was what was this sort of maybe early
years then of evolution what was one of
the maybe a couple the sort of first
real key milestone obviously the first
one getting at the seller obviously but
the first couple years obviously what
what was the sort of first milestone
where maybe you turned around to Nick
and was like right we're we're really
onto something here or sort of where was
the point where there's like right let's
really push on or we've got to a great
point here because obviously after year
one he had to change slightly I
treatment ends up being your neck but
what was the sort of first key milestone
I guess early on in evolution that
really sort of motivated you guys or
it's a question of that I think we were
we were lucky in that we ended up hiring
a number of people who had some
recruitment experience that maybe would
worked with previously or that had
worked at companies that we knew of and
even though it was never part of a a
plan would probably ended up with six or
seven people who knew how to do the job
and and what that allowed was the the
kind of owners and founders to take some
time to work on the business rather than
in the business because there was other
people that could generate fees so yes I
think I remember doing our first hundred
thousand pound bond
and thinking wow that's amazing you know
that is we are starting to get somewhere
here because if you yeah you multiply
that out that's over a million pounds
over a year and you think we've actually
got business so I think it was getting
those group of people that could
actually do the job and that freed up
time to work on the business rather than
in the business
what was the rough timeline of that
because again I think that's one of the
common challenges right and and why a
huge percentage of recruitment
businesses in the UK are sub-10 staff
it's because Gareth Morris the
recruitment business owner doesn't get
those people in early or isn't having
the mindset of making myself redundant
so I can do more on the on the business
so I guess what was the timeline of that
was it over a three four five year
period where you've got that opportunity
to have more of a get your head above
the water and think about on the
business yes it's a good question yeah I
don't think it was immediate
I do think it did take a little bit of
time I probably say two or three years
something like that so we probably ended
up with perhaps ten people in the
business and it meant that as I say we
could work on the business rather than
in the business mm-hmm okay so let's
just talk about that for a second
because I'd love to sort of just try and
sort of think about what your mindset
was at that point so obviously a couple
years in under obviously under five
years old
got people in their billing giving
yourself more time focus on the business
so I guess we're sort of coming up to
towards 2003 to 2005 right yeah so I
guess at that point what was the mindset
on how you're gonna grow this business
was it the typical let's get five more
careers in hopefully that means you
would be 200k months and then keep
growing it like that or obviously what
what were the sort of things that you
were thinking about that point again the
next part I think I think the while the
catalyst was it's very difficult to grow
a meaningful sized recruitment business
by only hiring people that have
experience because
there's just not huge numbers of good
quality people that are looking to join
small businesses you know people every
base area we were based at that stage in
Warrington so it moved from in
Warrington as well yeah exactly exactly
so I think I read a book called the
e-myth and I'm reading at the moment
yeah it's a really really good book and
it's saying that most people that start
businesses aren't truly entrepreneurs
for example most plumbing businesses are
started by people that enjoy plumbing
and then they don't particularly enjoy
running the business therefore the the
business doesn't really grow that's kind
of the premises it's the sort of
technician the manager and the
entrepreneur correct yeah just the
technician and just doing the work you
wear three hats effectively yes
so the I think one of the things that
sticks with me from that book is that
even if you aren't going to franchise
your business pretend you're going to
franchise your business and write
everything down that you do that you
think makes you successful or as though
you were going to charge someone for
that information as with the franchise
and I think what we did do and right
right from the the seller I remember
writing out like copious amounts of
training notes on how to do recruitment
and I think that if you can get a
process which you can teach to other
people and teach to people that no have
no reply recruitment experience then
you're on the road to scaling your
business I think it it's very difficult
to scale a recruitment business if
you're only hiring people with
experience you've got to be able to
train and develop trainees and people
that have never done the job before and
and to do that you need to break down
what you're doing and what you can do
successfully into an easy to follow
process for other people so you really
so that early period you really started
sort of our guess
cultivates in the evolution way document
saying yeah that you know we were and
when you when you say document just
quickly just to
really clear are we talking about this
is how we did business development when
you get a job these are the questions
you ask when you get a candidate this is
what you do on the system like are we
talking like yes yeah yeah so we
remember yeah kaki taking me back now
that a lot of the early training I wrote
and it was around recruitment skills
it was around technical knowledge of you
markets or understanding something about
IT and then there was the system skills
so there was a CRM system or database
and and I think you had to try and
transfer skills in all three areas to
people to help them to be successful and
I think at the beginning of someone's
career the queerer guide you can give
people of how to be successful in the
job the better they're going to be now
obviously one you see one six months in
once you're 12 months in people can
start to put their own stamp on it
and to innovate and and to try different
things but I think when you first start
in a role and someone genuinely has
never done a job before you know just
asking them to get on and give it a go
is is is just gonna be a recipe for
disaster really and again I think that's
I think the I think it's the process
part again you're doing things that
before you technically maybe needed them
because you could have sense of those
ten people get on the phone and I'll
help you as you go right but you were
documenting it so I love that so sort of
Gareth early on on the business was
right I really need to document if we
get to new people that don't have
recruiting experience we need they need
to know exactly how to do things when
they go through that door right okay
cool so I guess so then just quickly
then what about during this period
obviously coming up to 2005 around the
sort of first five year mark cause he
get in towards the sort of recession in
no way I guess like what was IT
recruitment back then because was
LinkedIn when when was linked when did
linkedin happen because that saucy a bit
of a master in it's a good questions
it's a really good question
I think that I think LinkedIn was
starting to become popular before the
credit crunch and before the downturn in
2007 2008 but probably really became
bigger afterwards after there and it was
mainly job board orientated was it for
that really yeah
Oh 2002 sorry I just yeah okay yeah but
I don't think it was massive in the in
the UK because what looking back then
would you like was because obviously
would you say it was less crowded like
it was it was quite quite easier and
like could you as you said it was more
job board orientated like did you have
to be obviously not as nice as you
probably have to be now I just I just go
backwards for for you really and when
when I was at computers the way you
attracted candidates with mister
advertised in the back of physical
magazine used to have to write your
adverts ten days before it went to press
by which time the jobs the jobs were
filled and you know computers to their
credit and dominated the advertising
they bought on all four of advertising
in computer Weekly in computing
magazines so we had a lot of candidates
so you know in terms of going to market
so the client side you had a lot of
product you know you have a lot of
people for them so they kind of they
kind of have to have to work with you
and then what happened was when the
internet came along and you got job
board site job serve and job site and
those types of companies it democratized
recruitment and it meant that you could
start off the business from your salary
or from your bedroom and if you
advertised on these job boards or you
logged onto their CV databases you could
actually get access to some of the
people that the computer futures
Heys or whoever they're the dominant
players were at the time had access to
so and I think LinkedIn is just a
natural continuation of that so the
internet definitely allowed us to start
our business up because you know
advertising and trade press was
thousands and thousands of pounds
advertising on job boards was hundreds
of pounds so it helped us but obviously
it helped lots of other people as well
so it meant you know if you've got an
awful lot of competitors then the only
way to combat that really is to
specialize in in a particular area and
be the best in the world at something
and I think you know that's really
important for for any recruiter starting
out is try to be a specialist in a
particular market rather than try and be
a jack-of-all-trades you know and accept
that you're not going to work with every
client and you're not going to be able
to help every candidate but be
absolutely brilliant in the area that
you choose to focus and specialize in
and your specialism was I team yeah yeah
but obviously within that we have
recruiters specializing in particular
vertical markets and you know the more
specialist that you can go the better
but if if people were starting up
businesses now you know IT it's way too
general to start a business and you'd
have to take a particular niche in a
particular area and say okay we're gonna
try and be the best in the world at this
particular area because I think there's
just too much competition out there now
to be a generalist okay and just quickly
just for context obviously honest or
talked a bit about what your business is
like going into the sort of financial
crash and and your experience there and
that what was you predominate on
business was a contract yeah
predominantly permanent okay you know
probably 90 percent of our net fees were
probably through permanent and temps and
on contract at the time so go into the
financial crash then what did your
business look like before that hit
I would say probably 3035 people
something like that and you know it was
a it's obviously a long time ago now and
pale pales into insignificance really
compared to the the coronavirus but I
think we were pretty lean so we didn't
have a big IT department we didn't have
a big marketing department we didn't
have anyone in HR we had you know the
owners of the business and recruiters
and some team leaders
so from memory we managed to ride out
the storm okay and by that I mean we
didn't lose money so we were still
profitable albeit that may have been a
fairly small profit and I think that's
what we did we just [ __ ] off accordingly
and we didn't make anyone redundant we
didn't you know ask anyone to leave the
business but obviously we're in
recruitment and if someone isn't making
placements month after month after month
sometimes people make their own decision
don't they in say actually this isn't
for me so probably coming out of that
credit crunch and financial crisis we
were left with our best people but just
less people and and very much like a
garden I suppose if you prune your
garden back it can grow better and and
and and and you know be more productive
on the other side so obviously going
through that war what do you think the
learnings through that period what do
you think applies to today obvious dick
completely different but like sort of
looking back and just talking about sort
of that period and that experience I
guess out of that what happened there
what what do you think sort of applies
today from what we learned during that
period and don't panic you know people
don't want that that the leader to be
panicking or or overly worried I think
make sensible logical decisions cuts out
any non-essential costs out of your
business
so things that people wouldn't make
if you stop spending money on them I
think support people and make sure that
people know that you know we've always
been relatively conservative in the way
we've run the business so we do have
money in the bank and let people know
that they need they need reassurance but
also if anyone hasn't were through a
recession or a downturn there is life on
the other side this this will not last
forever although it feels like it in
lockdown
it won't last forever and I think you
know tough times make tough people and I
think if if you your recruiters and your
business can get through this period you
probably look back and say it was
actually the best thing that ever
happened to us because you have to be
innovative you have to change and you
you have to kind of seize the day and
what will happen is you know that the
strong will survive and you'll have a
better stronger foundation to build from
albeit there might be a few less people
in your business because for some people
it you know it might become too much
mm-hmm okay first ten years then of
evolutions history then let's just sort
of tie that together so do like where
was you I so got through that I really
loved what he said there around the sort
of garden analogy yeah came out the
other side with even stronger people
that you probably felt even more
confident to build and grow a business
with and so where was you in 2010 how
many people where was your revenue wise
as well see so I'm assuming use around
thirty forty people whereas you revenue
wise and as a business ten years in do
you know what it's really good question
roughly I'm not gonna hold you to rip
its revenue ten million maybe something
like that I think one of the things that
we did do in the financial crisis is we
invested in training so we've made the
decision that if the jobs about to get a
lot harder for people we need to invest
in training them and we got a full-time
trainer into the business so
you know that early work that I'd put in
creating training documentation and
everything else this is part of scaling
your business hire someone who's better
than you at doing that particular part
of the job so you know I was okay at it
and you know I definitely helped a
number of people early on in the career
be be successful but if you've got
someone whose job it is full-time and
they're a training and development
expert they're going to do a better job
than me so we we invested in in training
and I think we got our first investors
in people certification back in 2009 so
a time where everyone else was probably
cutting their training teams budgets
departments etc we were just investing a
little bit more in that because we knew
that the job was going to be difficult
for people and we needed to support them
enough so just quickly on that because I
think this period is also highlighted
that and I think that's been quite a few
of the conversations that I've had with
recruitment business owners yeah I guess
just very quickly if you were to
summarize you investing then and
learning a development and well actually
recognizing that it is gonna be tough on
the other side of this yeah how did that
decision on investing in your people and
training enable your staff or how did it
have an impact as they bounced back I
guess it'd be good to get your
experience from that because that there
might be some similarities for yeah I
think it's supporting the people that
are doing the job on the frontline while
it's tough so even just someone to do a
coaching session to listen to understand
to empathize is is good but what it
allowed that person to do we brought in
in that training were always really to
learn the business and learn more about
recruitment and then as we started to
come out of that financial crisis that
person understood recruitment more so it
allowed us to recruit trainees because
the person understood the process they
understood what recruitment was and how
it all worked and then you know we would
recruit groups of trainees put them
through a training school
give them support give them training
give them development and obviously you
know a percentage of those would would
come out as successful when a decent
recruiters done on the other side hmm
okay so those first ten years then just
quickly and then let's sort of move into
the next decades yeah and knowing we
know now what do you wish sort of you
knew going into those first ten years or
the first couple years you think that
you wish I think yeah you got bear in
mind I was 25 when when when we started
the business so you know it's pretty
young as a person you know pretty
inexperienced as a recruiter and had to
learn an awful lot on the job so what
would have done differently perhaps
invested more time quicker in somebody
to work full-time in a training role to
then allow us to recruit a bigger volume
of trainings yeah exactly because I
think if you really want to get your
business moving you've got to accept
that you need to train people I've never
done the job before and help them to be
successful and that is quite complicated
there's a lot to learn you know it's
people say things like all recruitment
it's not rocket science well I would
argue that in this day and age with all
the tools that you've got available and
all the competition that's out there it
probably is rocket science so you know
you don't underestimate what you find
the easy yourself as a recruiter is
actually really challenging to train and
develop other people and and don't
underestimate that challenge and perhaps
if we started that process a little bit
earlier then would have been a bit
further on after after ten years hmm do
you think I don't know like I know it's
not because I'm thinking again that's
another sort of real big challenge as to
what prevents growth for recruitment
businesses and so guess I don't know do
you reckon that you could put a bit of a
trigger on when you should hire a
internal trainer or is it just as soon
as you could afford it consider having
some sort of internal training
resource yeah as soon as possible yeah
either that or you know if you've
started the business as a you know two
or three of you it might be that one of
you has a passion for doing that so it
doesn't have to be a new hire or it
might be somebody in your business who's
a good recruiter that maybe gets more of
a thrill by other people making
placements than making placements
themselves so it's maybe giving them a
an option occur a career development
opportunity and moving them into a you
know a training and development role but
I think if you are gonna scale up your
business you have to train people to do
the job if you if you want them to do it
well and do it successfully that would
be my experience okay so going into the
next decade then because I'm sure I'm
assuming at that point it was like wow
first ten years in business
I'm firstly that's amazing length of
time right so I'm sure there would have
been some sort of like right then on the
next decade this is our vision and this
sort of thinking I guess what what was
the mindset sort of of you and your
business partners going into the the
sort of eleventh and the future of that
I think I think I think it was that you
know the financial crisis where we we
kind of realized our long term goals for
the business I don't think we're gonna
realize these just being a uk-based
recruitment business really yeah and I
think there was very much there was a
lot of talk at the time about the the
power shifting from the west to the east
and China was gonna become the you know
that the biggest economy and the most
dominant player and I think we realized
that we needed to expand out over
sonication yeah outside outside of the
UK so I think from memory we had
probably about 50 odd people on board
when we started opening overseas offices
first in Germany and then in Singapore
and then in Australia and I think what
it does is provides a timeline on that
sorry just quickly before I forget
roughly I think Germany has been open
for around 10 years now
Singapore probably seven years Australia
about five years so
okay off off off yes that clicked so
there was clearly a real motivation then
to diversify the evolution brand into
not just a UK business then off the back
of the financial crisis yeah yeah I
think I think we just thought this is
too risky to just you know purely be a
UK IT recruitment business so that was
kind of a thing that stimulated us and
and nice story in terms of our German
office so many many years ago we had a
guy that joined us as a placement
student so he was if you do a degree in
Europe you have to do a placement that's
part of your degree and if you speak any
sort of English you tend to go and do it
in an english-speaking country because
it's a good skill to have so he came
over and work for us and you couldn't
actually pay them wages it was kind of a
strange system where you had to pay them
I think expenses really give 600 quid a
month you couldn't you could pay people
and he came over and work for us for he
was nine months but he spoke very very
good English and in that time he made
some placements he was actually pretty
good at the job so he finished his
degree and then came back and joined us
full time as an employee of the UK
business and he did a couple of years
work in the UK market but as the German
and then he his then wife got pregnant
and wanted to move back to Germany so he
moved back to Germany around the time of
the credit crunch we kept in contact and
then probably six to nine months later
as we're starting to come out of it we
said you know you've always wanted to
start your own business and we've always
wanted to or you know expand the
evolution outside the UK how about
starting something for us in Germany so
this guy that joined us as a placement
student has now ended up and MD of our
German business so you know our purpose
as a company is to help people and
organisations realise their potential
and he's a great example of someone that
you know was a student that did a
six-month placement and then became an
MD with a stake in his own business in
in Germany hmm so
so let's just talk about the
international expansion piece and that
wasn't my first question around sort of
what what the strategy was he just
shared a great story on how obviously
basically what you what you had there
was someone that soaks up the UK culture
yes or understood what the evolution way
was and then I feel like you'd be pretty
confident he'd be able to replicate that
or understand what your purpose and
mission is as a business which meant
that as a good chance he could recreate
that in another country so I guess I'll
see we could combine or see all the sort
of countries here that you've gone into
but I guess what was the the plan or
what was the strategy on how you were
gonna sort of penetrate these markets
these international markets has it
always been you've got someone from the
UK office and they started to work I've
seen these other international markets
and then they went over there I guess
what what was how did you approach it
well Germany was a little bit of a
unique situation really and I think it
would be difficult for the other
companies to replicate but what I would
say with with regards to the other
offices is you've got to find a great
person to setting' on I think you know
the success of that office is going to
be probably 80 to 90 percent down to
that person that person so find someone
that you trust find someone that shares
you values and and and find someone with
local market knowledge experience so you
know probably has been working in that
market ideally five years you know
they've got some relationships they've
got some knowledge of which companies
hire and which companies are easy to
recruit for and which are more
challenging and then what we did was
talk that local person and then a
business partner at the time would then
go out to those offices and spend you
know eat up to a couple of years out
there to make sure the evolution DNA was
was over in the office as well yeah
absolutely so I would say someone with
local market knowledge is a must and
somebody with your DNA teamed up would
be the best because I think that that
agent that's the challenge right because
if I'm if I'm speaking to recruiting
Singapore like obviously that you said
trust right we'll see if they haven't
worked for evolution before and it's a
new hire you're backing them to do it
you go I mean I'm see that it can be
quite hard to get that right or you're
worried about getting that right because
obviously as you said 89 percent the
success of that would be down to that
person so I guess what what was what was
the cell then because obviously they
they'd have most the leverage like if
I'm a local person know the market and
sort of one speaking to you is a UK
recruitment business and saying look the
what was the opportunity for me and sort
of what did you make sure you saw in
that person for you to go yeah this is
the person we want to hang out head up
our Singapore or Australian office I
think that we we made sure that there
was share options available for those
people in in those offices based on on
hitting targets because obviously
they're integral to that office and you
want them to be tied in to the long-term
success so that's one way to you know to
make sure that people are loyal and and
therefore the long term how did you
stretch that there's really simply just
because I think sometimes it there can
be dis a lot of them smoke and mirrors
with yeah you can get shares equity or
whatever but how did you life on
thinking about opening an American
office and speak to someone at the
moment or whatever what was it like how
did you structure it to favor then but
also favor you it just just document the
agreement you know just make sure put it
into a contract to exhale if you do X Y
and Zed you get this percentage of of
that particular business and you know
the thing with share options is they are
executable upon an event upon selling
the business or floating the business so
you only get to benefit if you're there
at the end and that's what you want that
person tied in to be part of the journey
not to do two years and then and then
disappear they hit milestones and they
get some of the profit share which in
the short term long term it's a sheer
reward if you're running an office you
need to put some sort of profit share
scheme in place and that's only right
and proper but for the longer term it's
okay you know if we sell this business
then
you're gonna get a percentage of the
value of that your office is grated hmm
so what are the common misconceptions
recruitment business owners have on
expanding international internationally
do you think you'd have to ask them all
the common misconceptions I don't know I
think that was your biggest challenge
probably penetrating a market when you
when you're on a standing start
you know because let's not kid ourselves
most areas of the world have people
doing recruitment already so you've got
to go over there and offer something
different or something better and you
know sometimes that takes time to get
known doesn't it if you if you've just
starting up a business it doesn't matter
if you you've got some formal reputation
in the UK or in Germany no one knows you
in Sydney or in Australia so you've got
to start start out from scratch that's
the biggest challenge isn't it when you
turn up you have no reputation and
that's why I think the person who starts
in the office probably needs to have
that local market knowledge and you know
be in a position where they've maybe got
some relationships and some reputation
themselves that they can bring to the
party hmm and then and then just just a
quick one and also know that you said
obviously you have someone that went
over there typically but yeah I guess
what how did you get better instilling
the evolution DNA what was sort of the
core because obviously Singapore
recruitment office culture is going to
be different to your office in Warrenton
right and you've got to respect that and
understand that so I guess how have you
gone about yeah how have you gone about
ensuring that that DNA in purposes
transfers across all different brands
and do you make sure that I don't know
that the UK team know that actually they
do have offices in Australia new trying
sort of cultivate and these people to
share knowledge and I don't know what
how have you gone about sort of
cultivating this of group you
it's I think it comes from the global
board so each of the offices has that
the person that runs that office is on
the global board so when we've done work
I'm defining and you know honing down on
our purpose and our brand promise and
our values those people have been
integral in that process so they then
believe in what that purpose is what the
brand promise is and what values are
because they co-created it and then it's
their job to go and instill that into
their their offices and I think you know
if they have helped to create yeah get
them involved and that vision then
they're more likely to go and sort of
make sure that their office actually
lives lives lives and breeds it right
now so I'd say a rough rule of thumb for
us is everybody has the same purpose the
same brand promise and the same values
and 80% of the culture of the offices is
probably the same but then 20% has to be
kind of unique to that yeah good good
example being Singapore team-based
events and more round food than they are
around alcohol because culturally that's
what what matters to them our German
business kind of changed that the dress
code and dress down a lot earlier than
the other offices because that's what
mattered to them they still shared the
values of the business they still shared
the brand promise and the purpose but
what you do is some of the subtleties
are different from from office to office
hmm so what does an a she was like for
you in your opinion scaling this
recruitment business as you have
expanded internationally like how
important were your company values and
purpose when actually growing your
business do you think how important are
they because I'll see you hear about
hear about them all the time you see
people put them on their website
obviously bencher office you have my
view walls and I guess what how
important are they when growing your
recruitment business
I think they're really important because
I think it gives people an idea of the
personality of the business and what's
important to that business and they make
a choice do I want to be part of that or
do I not so you end up with a group of
like-minded people albeit who you know
you still want innovation don't you
still want people that are capable of
doing things a little bit different or
trying things or experimenting but you
know our brand promise for example is to
provide a great recruitment experience
so whether it's a candidate that we're
placing a contractor or requiring we
want them to come away from that
interaction and promoting our service we
want them to be advocates of our
business and if someone doesn't really
share that then they're probably not
right to work in our business because if
they just want to do a deal and you know
they don't care if they leave about
taste in people's mouths then that isn't
sustainable long term and you know that
that's really important to us to make
sure that people share that vision
really are providing a great recruitment
experience whoever they're talking to
so obviously the values part then also
helps you say no to people we'll get
more of the right people basically as
you're hiring and growing
yeah and we're really it's really really
simple
when we when we were assess for
investors and people back in 2009 the
lady that did the assessment said you
know what you really impressive company
people love working for the business
they speak passionately about it and
they say the same sorts of things about
your business but you know what you
haven't actually got any values
documented so we we went through a
process then of talking to everyone in
the business and saying okay well what
do you think's important and and getting
workshops together and getting people to
do some brainstorming and we came up
with with seven values and you know a
number of that was co-created with
co-created at time in 2009 and all it
was was it was it was documenting what
we were anyway they were always there
they just weren't weren't explicit and
it was this lady that did our IIP
sort of assessment that frankly up to us
just said it's crazy you know you it's
so clearly you've got values in your
business but you've just not kind of
stopped to write them down and then a
number of years later it became clear
that sevens just too many for people and
we there was also hygiene factors in
there you know things like professional
well the I suppose the key there is if
someone isn't professional they just
shouldn't be working in your business
it's not something that you should be
aspiring to be you should just be taken
as read so we took the seven values and
we did another work shopping session
many years later with everybody in the
different offices and we said what which
of these values is most important to you
and we boiled it down to three and that
was to be ambitious innovative and
collaborative and and I think when we
hire ambition I'm looking for someone
who wants to achieve something in their
life that has goals meaningful goals
that they're prepared to work hard
towards if somebody doesn't have
ambition the best thing you can do is
not offer them a job because you're just
gonna do them a disservice because in
recruitment in this era
unless you're ambitious it's gonna be
really really difficult for you
innovative the world's changing
recruitments changing at a faster pace
than it's ever changed before so you've
got to be capable of taking onboard new
ideas and running with them and also
coming up with a few yourself you can't
just always rely on someone else to tell
you what to do and to explain you know
how to do recruitment sometimes you need
to join some of the doctors yourself and
finally and probably most importantly
being collaborative so we achieve more
by working together and I think you know
in recruitment you do get people who are
individual contributors and that's ok
but you can't be toxic to the colleagues
around you your success can't mean that
someone else isn't successful as a
result and and I think that's really
really important that I'd much rather
you know a B+ team player then the the
the a star individual contributor that
ruins everything around
hmm so and keen to sort of just talk a
bit about how you and scale do your
business obviously going to the next ten
years after that first decade but I
guess obviously the real motivation
going to after those 10 years was the
diversification international expansion
yeah so our after obviously you have
achieved that I guess overall now even
you can talk about from from where you
are now I guess but how much of an
impact did that then have on the
profitability of your recruitment
business then because that something
that you learned during the financial
crisis and thinking well actually we'll
probably have more longevity as a
business like did it then that hasn't
made your business more profitable yeah
I mean I would say opening international
offices in the short term it's an
investment so in my experience don't
expect to make huge amounts of profit
within the first two or three years but
what you're doing is trying to invest
for five years time so it takes time you
know you've got to get office space
you've got a hire someone to start the
office you've got a higher employees who
aren't necessarily going to be
productive straightaway but you've got
to stick with it so you've got a you've
got to invest for them for the long term
so I'd say opening any overseas offices
in the short term you're likely to make
less profit in the short term but long
term you've given yourself another
growing point you've given yourself
another way to grow your business grow
your net fees and grow your profits oh
yeah longer-term it will help you to
become more profitable short term you've
got to accept you can have to spend
money to make money
it's definitely long term it's increase
the equity value of evolution and your
business yeah because it into an
international recruitment business is
generally gonna be worth more than yeah
you know one that's just operates in one
particular country and then I guess to
bring it I get I was gonna say also then
to bring it today
but and then globally we've been
affected by this as I said how useful is
it being to be sort of diversified in
terms of different being in different
continents because maybe it has maybe it
hasn't but I think also a financial
crisis it wasn't a global it wasn't a
global event was it I guess has it
helped being diversified in the current
challenges would you say maybe more so
in Australia maybe yeah I think you know
they the coronavirus hasn't really
wreaked havoc in Australia that said
they were very proactive a bit as a
country about going into lockdown so
they still had lots of the same
challenges but I'd say their economy is
moving a bit quicker now than them for
example the economy in in in the UK
Singapore
you know after China was hit quite early
and then seems to get hold of things and
then suddenly a month to later went into
lockdown because a lot of the migrant
workers in Singapore ended up with the
coronavirus Germany again their money to
control of coronavirus very successfully
but one of the challenges we've got in
Germany is that employment rights for
permanent employees are very strong
they're very employee centric and even
if people are on their version of the
furlough scheme in Germany they're only
paid 60 or 67 percent of their salary
based on whether they've got family or
not but Germans are still keen to stay
with their existing employer rather than
take the risk of Muslim yeah yeah
because the way employment law works in
Germany is that you have very few
employment rights in the first six
months and then you are very much
protected thereafter you know our
permanent IT candidates are still
nervous about moving jobs even if they
are not actually actively working for
their businesses because they're still
getting some income and they're kind of
yeah risk-averse if you like about and
putting themselves into that position
when they're in their probationary
period with a new business ok interest
in and so I guess thinking of sort of I
mean a lot of people will sort of have
the mindset that they want to grow their
recruitment business obviously cercano
60 people a lot of people write
different offices I guess just just
thinking about that for a sec what do
you think I'll see you invested
to training clearly from the very
beginning documented your process but
guess what would you say with some of
the key factors that enabled you to
scale your recruitment business to the
the amount of people you have was it the
the strategy of getting people bulk of
people for your academy and doing it
that way or what would you say were some
of the key sort of aspects to enabling
you to scale would you say yeah I think
if you if you think about it and logical
order you've got to have good people
doing internal recruitment because
arguably it's the most important job in
your business if you hire really good
people with great potential then a
decent percentage of them or work out to
be successful recruiters yeah so get
your IRI
in the first instance and then once
you've got the right plan so when did
when did you did when did you will start
building that Tim out of interest over
10 years ago yeah I think we just found
that the rectorate companies we work
with which is very sporadic really in
the people that they could or would send
us so we had no choice there we had we
had to build an internal team because
there was no way we could we could grow
hire
wrecks wreck candidates and the people
who have worked internal in internal
recruitment have done a great job
they've recruited people with the right
kind of raw attributes raw skills and
then obviously we've slaughtered them
into this training program and training
process to give them the best chance of
being successful no one can guarantee
anything but what you're trying to do is
give people the best possible chance hmm
so investing in Aussie or internal
recruitment function yeah and then going
down the training program Academy route
so that what did that mean that you was
able to I don't know hire 10 15 8 people
at once rather than yeah that would that
was that was it's become more difficult
over the last few years because the
country's been virtually at full
employment in the UK so getting a
quantity of people to start on one day
is very very
ethical but yeah historically we would
we would recruit a you know a group of
people and I think that works really
well in many many ways a it gives people
peers to compete against when the first
start in the jobs and you can make it a
bit of fun secondly they've got friends
in the business straightaway you know if
you think about it walking into a
company where there's maybe a hundred
people in an office and you're the
newbie that's a little bit overwhelming
for some people whereas if you're
starting on the same day as three or
four other people you've immediately got
friends to go you know go for lunch with
chat with talk through the training with
you know support you in terms of when
when you're on the phones making calls
and trying to make your way and
recruitment if you you know your only
point of reference is your manager who's
been doing it for ten years that's
that's quite difficult isn't it but if
you are in it with other people like you
I think that helps gives people peer
peer support since we've we've spoken a
lot about getting new people into the
business what would have been the key
things you've done to retain that the
best people in your your business I mean
I've met a couple of people in your
business and I think online a lot of
people are you and I better than me but
it seems like a lot of people have
worked eeveelution for quite a long
period so I guess what have been some of
the key things that are contributed to
you keeping hold of some of your best
people would you say I think there's a
few things really one is the way you
treat people so I think as a person I
genuinely care about our purpose of
helping people realize the potential so
people who go on achieve success in our
business I'm really really proud that
they've done that not for me but for
them and I think people know that that
sincere I don't think you can make that
up on a day-to-day basis when you see
these people every day you play football
with them you you know you go on social
events with them and things like that
people see through if that's not how you
really are so be sincere be fair
put their best interests at heart not
your best interests leaders should eat
last not not first and I think people
know that
I think there's trust there hopefully
that people know in the DNA of the
business we do care about them we do
want them to be successful and you know
what people do leave
that's recruitment nobody will stay with
you forever and even people have gone on
perhaps they've gone overseas moved out
of the industry I'm still pleased when I
see other people doing well you know if
you know I've had people reach out to us
that haven't worked for us for five
years and say you know what you gave me
a great start in recruitment I enjoyed
my three or four years with your
business you know yeah they're still the
best company will work for or whatever
it's really nice when people remember
that and come back years later to say
that and I think you know you've always
got an advocate and a friend for the
future so yeah treat treat people how
you'd want to be treated be fair try and
see things from the other person's
perspective it's always really easy to
see things from your own perspective in
life but try and con sit sit on the
other side of the fence and you know
give people opportunity as well you know
I think this is definitely with Falco
being the example in Germany people have
started different brands for us started
divisions grown teams move batches you
know if you can give people a fresh
challenge every so often in a career
that helps as well because you can't
just do the same thing day in day out
for four ten years and the view if you
had to cultivate that mindset because I
do believe that's true I mean I haven't
been to your office it's big office and
we can see there sat there on the floor
and you've seen you've seen someone
that's really approachable and I think
if you think 160-person business and I
can see the CEO sitting over there he's
not in that you know in a corner office
and I don't have to go through a couple
of doors to find you and you go I mean
so I guess have you been on the journey
with that yourself or has that just been
sort of been lately how you how you've
been I think
probably a couple of things I think it
is in my purse now let's see you know I
don't think you can fake caring about
other people you are or you don't and I
think that I realized very early on that
the success of the business relied on
other people so you better be nice to
them because they're you know they're
there they're there more importance of
the success of the business than I am
I'm only one person
did you find that hard to let go of that
because I think that's the check like
your ego can get in a way of that and
like you started this business in your
cellar and you're going on other people
more important I don't don't really have
any ego at all you know I think it is
genuine where there's a lot of people in
our business that are better than lots
of aspects of our business than I am
I suppose what I've done well this is
find those people and encourage them to
join our business and then empowered
them to get on with their job and then
support them and and and you know what
support them when things aren't going
well because everybody's a hero when
when things are going well when
someone's made a mistake just empathize
and sympathize and said you know what in
the same position I think it'll probably
have made the same mistake myself so
don't beat yourself up about it and you
know as long as you learn from it just
try not to make the same mistake again
and I think you know I did read a book
how to win friends and influence people
by Dale Carnegie as a granite it's a
brilliant book but in terms of how to
treat other people and that probably and
goes such a long way yeah but it
probably crystallized what I already
felt was the right thing to do yeah but
but but gave me confidence that that
actually yeah this this is the way I
want to be this is this is how I want to
be remembered and you know I want people
at work for the business to think great
business and a great person not not
because I'm some you know heroic leader
just because they feel as though I had
their back and I supported them and
helped them especially when it's when it
when times are difficult
don't actually love that guy's fingers
and they're the types of things that you
don't typically associate with
recruitment or a recruiter or so I just
love that I think that's great I think
doing the right thing really goes a long
way and like it sounds basic and simple
but you can build a great profitable big
business by having that type of mindset
and nothing that's that's awesome so
before we finish I know obviously two
paths unpack twenty years of your
business but I guess just before we
finish what I'd love to just get your
focus on Gareth is I think when you when
you've been in business for that long
and I feel like that you could be
susceptible to being comfortable or
getting complacent and sort of you you
could very easily have the mindset of
well we did it this way five years ago
so that's how we're doing it you go I
mean so I guess what sort of been your
journey with ensuring the evolution
recruitment although you're twenty years
old and you build a sustainable business
which is amazing but what have you done
to make sure that you don't get left
behind and as you said recruitment is
changing as fast as it ever has in new
ways here sort of old-school recruiters
or old-school recruitment now so I guess
what have you done in your business to
make sure that you know you're not put
in that box of over evolution they're
they're old-school they've been around
twenty years what would because that
could be quite difficult right so I
guess how have you found that journey
and what have you done always invested
in technology so we've always had a
bespoke CRM system we've got an in-house
IT team we are ourselves Microsoft Gold
partners as a business for the quality
of the IT team so with over the last
probably 12 to 18 months redeveloped our
CRM system from scratch in you know
latest technologies cutting-edge
technologies which allows integration
with the things like LinkedIn and the
tools that people are just using as a
standard I think that having or defining
being innovative as one of our values is
really important and I think often the
innovation comes from the floor so
having said earlier that when people
start in the industry it's
teaching them process and I believe that
it that it absolutely is what you've
then got to do probably six to 12 months
in he's give people the confidence to
try things and to innovate and and and
to take chances and take risks and if it
succeeds to then go and tell the rest
the business about it so one of the most
best things we do really is raw master
classes with recruiters who are doing
the job who are trying things and when
they achieve success consistently then
in their own words tell the rest of the
business I've done and how they've done
it well so the innovation comes from
listening and talking to people who are
on the front line who are doing the job
and talking to your best builders and
talking to you know even your ok billows
and saying what's working what's not
when you say that's working do you think
you could write a master class about
that you think you could document that
in some form of process that other
people could understand and then they
get experience of presenting in front of
the colleagues and you know what I found
over the years is that people often want
to hear about new ideas from people who
are doing the job like them rather than
someone like me who you know it sort of
lasted recruitment and again that's
that's just don't don't take it
personally
people want to hear from people who are
actually doing the job and in your top
billa's now not what some a of so again
is true humility right and that's really
course it's come from actually sort of
you but you making sure that people are
living and breathing your values and
your cultivating those things that you
just said through your people which
makes it more current and can drive
influence internally not from you but
actually from the people that are on the
front line let them tell the story
because they'll do it far better far in
a far more convincing way and people can
identify with people like themselves
they were doing the job now in in this
era and you know what there's so much
good stuff that is going on in our
recruiting business and all the
recruitment business is out there but
just take
time to listen to the people and what
they're doing and then encourage them to
document it
you know back to that process think how
are you doing this really good thing
right you can't just have a quick chat
with someone else about it
you just need to write it down and and
you know that remembering a phrase you
haven't got a strategy until it's
written down well if someone's doing
something great but they can't really
document it it's not going to help you
change it forward yet get it in a
presentation share it with people and
then hopefully other people can learn so
that's amazing and so before so I guess
just quickly before I just ask you a
couple ask questions so what what does
what does a CEO of your business do now
then so talking a lot about other people
like what because I cuz like yeah what a
view what have you ended up really
focusing your time on and resource on
like as a CEO of a hundred person
recruitment business what would you end
wasn't typical day at like for you then
yeah
I think I'm someone who is quite
hands-on but by nature so a number of
the the different departments still
reporting to me I've got two very good
managing directors in the UK business
who run the sales teams and then got
very good people running our overseas
teams but you know in terms of our
development and data team our internal
recruitment team HR team there's still a
number of functions that do report in to
me so I make sure I suppose on a
day-to-day basis that what we're setting
is our strategy is a business is what
we're actually get doing on it on a
daily basis because you can have the
best strategy in the world if it's not
implemented correctly it's it's still
gonna fail and it's you know constantly
reminding people of our purpose which is
to help people and organisations to
realize their potential so if you're a
manager in our business your job is to
help your team realise their potential
yeah if you're a recruiter your jobs to
help your candidates and clients to
realize their potential
make sure that our brand promise is
upheld we you know we do a lot of net
promoter score surveys so you know we've
got a net promoter score plus eighty
three at the moment which is higher than
Apple Amazon and Netflix and that means
that the majority of people interact
with our business promote you know
promoters of our business and it's also
making sure that you know people are
living our values and and and yeah
praising and rewarding people that are
doing the right things you know be it
ambition on the sales side and people
you know producing great figures or
people who are running master classes
and being collaborative or people are
coming up with new ideas that they can
then roll out to the rest of the
business so I suppose it's you know
helping and supporting all the other
people that are quite frankly more
important than me in the business do
their job effectively while making sure
that this cohesion and coherence between
you know what we're trying to achieve
business so um final sort of question
then and then I'll actually the last
question and we'll see I'd be stupid to
not ask sort of what your opinion
perspective is on sort of just putting
Co vid 19 aside a second just sort of
the future of the recruitment industry
obviously you've you've been in
recruitment for a real while and
obviously back to your point of
recruitment is rapidly changing faster
than ever has before I guess where where
does your sort of mind and force go when
you think the future of the our industry
would you say what what comes up for you
when you think about the future of
recruitment
I think specialists rather than
generalist and I think if you're an
individual recruiter or your renewal
recruiting business you've got to think
about what can you be the best in the
world that and and I think the people
what I've seen beats most successful as
recruiters have a genuine interest and
passion about the sector that they're
recruiting in so they're attending
meetups they're reading articles they're
watching YouTube videos and they're
trying to add value genuinely trying to
add value to their candidates and
clients so
think unless you doing that I think it's
gonna be very challenging AG going
forward but that said I still
passionately believe that recruitment
done well is a he's a brilliant job in
in a brilliant industry so you know how
many industries are there where you can
help somebody realise their potential in
their career by finding them that the
next job it you know in their career
ladder helping companies to grow because
ultimately a business is only as good as
the people that work there and if you're
providing a business with great people
you're helping to grow that business
you're making a real difference and and
also you know from a recruiters
perspective you've got an opportunity to
progress your career really really
rapidly
you know you've even got an opportunity
to achieve the same number of promotions
you would in any other industry probably
you know it's eighty ten years in in in
a typical industry it might take you two
or three in recruitment and obviously if
you're successful then it can be
rewarding as well financially but I
think that's the byproduct of doing a
great job I think if it's only about
making money then sooner or later you
will get found out I think you've got to
have a sincere you know passion for
helping the candidates and the clients
to be successful and then business
starts to come to you you know people
refer you and recommend you promote your
service and the job starts to become
easier and again it sounds basic but
you'd be surprised how many people don't
have that intention and don't do the
right thing by their clients and
candidates and yeah it will go a long
way so I guess just just quickly then
and sort of a fun sort of aspiring
recruitment entrepreneur or on the real
cream and business owner right now
that's looking at sort of you and your
business and thinking wow I'd love to
sort of get to the point where they are
or whatever I guess what would you say
if I have a recruitment business right
now and I want to scale my business and
to sort of the heights of you guys what
what should I be thinking about what
would you be saying to me if I wanted to
be sort of where you are in the next
five to ten or so years I think it's
important to learn from the past
but not actually try and replicate it
because the world's changing so what
worked in the past isn't necessarily
going to work in the future I'd say you
know inch wide and mile deep so try and
pick something that has good long-term
prospects as a market and try and
dominate a niche rather than go general
and just you know sort of not even touch
the sides so try and be really famous
for doing something rather than try and
doing everything for everybody because I
think that's gonna be really really
difficult going going forward and in
terms of yeah anybody that's sort of
joined joining the industry as a
recruiter is the one thing you can
control is how hard you work so people
have more sales experience more sales
skills more empathy more persuasion
skills than others you can work on that
but what everybody can decide is how
hard they work on a day to day basis and
you know if you want to be successful in
this industry I think you've got to be
take a genuine interest in the market
that you do you've got to be wants to be
seen as an expert and to be able to add
value but you're gonna need to work hard
so if you read any book of any
successful business person any
successful politician or sports person
you can see virtually on every page how
hard they've had to work to get to where
they are and you know this is my my rant
I've got you know children I've got
three girls youngest is nine eldest is
at sixteen and my worry is the social
media gives people the edited highlights
of everyone else's life that looks
brilliant sometimes isn't actually true
and the bit that is not promoted is how
hard someone's had to work to get the
outcome that they're then busy showing
everybody on social media
and I really do worry for a generation
of people that they don't understand the
inputs that you have to put in to get
the nice shiny things
and yeah you know as the output and I
just hope that that doesn't I give a
whole generation of people unrealistic
expectations to say we'll actually
required what's required to be
successful because you should just read
books of people who are successful and
they're not working three or four hours
a day it's what it's one of the most
common demand one of the common things
that everyone says when I say what are
the sort of top traits in top billa's
that you've seen work ethic is always up
there and now you're completely right
it's why I'm completely obsessed with
sport documentaries that because
normally football basketball cricket is
the latest one I'm watching on Amazon
Prime called the test which is
unbelievable I don't like cricket but I
just love it for the reason that you're
talking about because in the high level
sports you see the finished article you
see the person on the tennis court you
see the person on the football pitch but
we've now in the world way actually
documentary is like this and stuff of
that they can compete behind the curtain
and see the hard work that Michael
Jordan put in and the amount of free
shot free throws that you threw before
you go onto that court and I think and I
don't know that's why they're resonating
me so much because it's just work ethic
and everything else it's just so good to
promote that and showcase that you can
write people need to understand what's
required and it's okay to think actually
and not sure that I want to work in
recruitment but yeah sure I want to put
that level of effort in but I think if
you intend on being successful in your
life you need to understand what's
required and I think more than that and
yeah you know the edited highlights of
someone's life on social media it looks
brilliant doesn't it looks absolutely
brilliant but what they're not telling
you is all the hard work that's taken
them to get to that point and and I
think is up to people like us to tell
people the truth because you know that's
been I suppose
my mantra you know as a as a business
owner as a manager is you've got to be
honest with people you can't say to
people in the interview process how
don't worry you know you can turn up and
turn when you want and make a couple of
calls and you know this time make sure
you'll be earning hundred thousand
pounds it's just not true but work
really really hard build the market
takers as they're interested in what
you're doing
care be passionate and you know what if
you do all those things for a sustained
period of time you will have a really
really good career and and you'll make a
really really good living but that's the
by-product it's not just something that
gets can I get gifted to you you know I
love that that final question and what I
was asked what were you excited about
Gareth what what is the future of
evolution that lot obviously post
cohered what what yeah were you excited
about a shower bath great great question
do you know what I think the resilience
that the business has shown today with
the coronavirus has been exceptional I
think the ability of everybody to work
from home effectively and to still
produce results has been has been you
know amazing really to see we set out
this year to roll out our new CRM system
around each of the offices and I've got
to be honest when when the coronavirus
here I thought okay that's gonna be
really difficult in our overseas offices
so in q2 we're rolling out to Australia
obviously the flights got cancelled
developers couldn't get over there and
what they've done is by great
collaboration by a lot of early mornings
from the UK team and late nights from
the Australian team we're actually ahead
of schedule and by the end of this
quarter we will roll out the new CRM
system to Australia and they've said
it's made a huge difference to them the
experience is better it's quicker
it handles latency better is helping
them do the job more effectively is
using kind of cutting-edge technologies
and I suppose if we can get to the end
of this year and despite the fact that
probably no one from the UK will have
been able to travel to an overseas
office we've still managed to roll out
that new CRM system successfully to the
to the other offices that will be there
exciting because that was a long-term
plan which could have easily been
disrupted but at the moment due to
people finding away and being innovative
the the rollouts actually got better in
Australia than we could have possibly
hoped for I love that look I've been an
absolute pleasure thank you
yep thanks very much for your time